est membre de la compagnie paling one
day avec laquelle il répète dans une
représentation
[Musique]
et toujours calme comme ça moi je ne
sais pas
[Musique]
bonjour tonton bonjour
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tu vois ce que tu as fait à mes amis
les enfants sale là ce sont vos enfants
je te permets pas de dire les enfants
sales et qui viennent salir
[Rires]
a
[Musique]
bien souvent les spectacles de
marionnettes sont donnés à l'occasion de
fête anniversaire ou encore pour des
arbres de Noël du mois de décembre
si on peut considérer que les enfants y
trouvent leur compte force de constater
que le contexte ne répond pas au minimum
d'exigences qui permettrait aux artistes
de s'exprimer pleinement
[Musique]
les règles économiques cette terrible
obligation de vivre ou plutôt de
survivre font que les marionnettistes
acceptent souvent de faire un peu
n'importe quoi pour un cachet souvent
dérisoire
[Musique]